here are some questions that I got from
a brainwave a children science magazine
in in India and the first question right
here is last month September the
students of the world celebrated
teachers day an overwhelming number of
whom would undoubtedly have sent their
wishes in gratitude your way hopefully
and knowing I thank everyone for for all
of the thank you notes we do get on our
youtube channel and all the rest who was
your favorite teacher who was your
favorite teacher while studying and why
you know I'd have to say I had I had a
bunch of favorite teachers for I guess
multiple reasons but I guess there is a
common thread i would say in high school
the teachers who and I don't want to
just pick favorites i'm sure i'm
forgetting some some very important
people here but mr. Hernandez who was
the first time i had a class with him
for algebra 2 but he was also the
advisor for the it was called mu alpha
theta which is kind of the math Honor
Society and also kind of the math
competition team he was our advisor for
that and and and miss Kennedy who was
our she was an English teacher and also
a journalism instructor and so when I
was on the school newspaper she was kind
of our our our teacher and our advisor
and and I think what made both of them
kind of memorable to me and I think
we're important in my own development is
that they really did treat me like a
peer they didn't they never talk down to
me they never said you know they did it
never felt like I am the teacher you're
the student it was it was kind of a
two-way flow of information and it
almost felt like we were you know we
were working together towards common
goals mr. Hernandez with you know some
of the stuff we do with the the math
team miss Kennedy with some of the stuff
we would do with the newspaper she was
just kind of a person who was more
knowledgeable and more experienced but
she really respected everything that we
were doing and I think you know they're
probably all the teachers that I had
that then I think really impacted me
kind of that that's what was what did it
for me is that I remember even in fifth
grade I had a teacher miss Ellis and you
know she would run her fifth grade
social studies classes kind of like a
college seminar remember I just drink we
remember her kind of being at the front
of the class peeling an orange and just
asking us tough questions and and you
know type of questions where you kind of
have to ponder it for a few seconds
before
you'd even kind of have an interesting
thought or you'd continue upon during or
when you went home and I remember there
was a miss miss Kraus and Miss rousselot
in elementary school they were gifted
teachers and once again they had the
luxury of kind of defining what their
own curriculum was but they you know
they really used to challenge us and and
and and give us truly creative projects
to work on they used to you know I when
you take art class outside of that often
times it's very formulaic it's very it's
kind of paint by numbers for lack of a
better word but I remember when we did
art projects in the context of the
gifted class it was really very
open-ended it was like here's some tools
make something and and and I think that
was a really strong message and it
allowed students to actually develop
their creativity as opposed to just
following following a formula so across
the board i think it's the teachers who
have who really treated who really
expected something from the students and
treated them with respect even though
you know these these students were
clearly early in their learning but but
and also assume that the students were
capable of true creativity I'll tour
another one in there dr. santanaya my
junior and senior year in high school I
took courses at the at the University of
New Orleans and dr. santonio was the
professor for partial differential
equations and he he kind of brought me
under his wing and for summer I I was
essentially kind of his kind of one of
his researchers and I you know and he
would kind of come into the little
computer lab where I was working and he
would talk about his research and we
would bounce ideas off of each other and
it was that type of kind of you know
being true you know clearly you know
here you are a tenured professor at
university but you're willing to hang
out with a 16 or 17 year old it really
kind of sent a very strong message to me
and really I think built my my own
self-esteem and made me think that I
could I could do something question
number two what sort of a student were
you at school um I was I was a kid who
loved so I loved I loved and this is
kind of an interesting answer i think
it's it's i loved a lot of the subject
matter and i hated a lot of the classes
and it was just I I found a lot of the
subject matter really really really
interesting I just didn't like how it
was kind of how it was sometimes
presented that and it wasn't the fault
of the teacher was often more usually
was the fault i would say of the
textbook or of just the curriculum
generally but but just you know the
general idea everything was devoid of
connections you would learn how to how
to borrow numbers without anyone telling
you why you're borrowing it that way or
even it without anyone ever asking the
students why does this work without ever
having a chance to ponder why does it
work you learn you know for you know
you'd see peers kind of memorize one
formula for one exam and then on the
next exam they or by the next month
they've forgotten it and the next year
when there's a topic that just builds
off of that same formula that kind of if
you just intuitively understood the
original formula the second one would be
intuitive there remem'er izing index
formula so i really didn't like that
that aspect of of what was going on and
I sometimes kind of i think for lack of
a better word i think i sometimes acted
up because of that I was actually
earlier on I kind of straightened up a
little bit near the end of high school
but earlier on I was I wasn't like the
discipline problem kid but I definitely
got a lot of you know my teachers
talking to my mom about you know Sal not
being fully engaged in class I think you
know once i got to to college you know I
I was lucky enough to go to a place
where there there was a lot of
intellectual curiosity going on the
peers were kind of there was a culture
of people wanted wanting to learn and I
frankly think MIT is somewhat unique in
that is that the culture really is i
mean there's other things going on on
campus but most of the people there
genuinely want to learn and there's no
embarrassment of saying that you're
actually fascinated by something
academic while a lot of schools in the
world I think there's almost you almost
have to hide that you're you're
interested in something I know that was
definitely the case in my high school
experience is that you know I would I
would I would not even if I was
fascinated with by something I would
kind of keep it to myself for and and
and though and sometimes even if even if
I I did enjoy talking to the teacher or
so I would actually keep that to myself
and I wouldn't want you know my peer
seeing that I was
even you know or sometimes I wouldn't
talk to the teacher for for being for
fear of being looked looking like you're
you know you're trying to be teachers
pet or something and I think sometimes I
would maybe overcompensated in the other
direction but yeah I would say I mean
I'm giving a long meandering answer I
would say as a student I was definitely
intellectually curious I definitely
liked to ponder things I did not like to
be kind of given I didn't like to paint
by numbers I guess is a simple way to do
it and and I oftentimes kind of butted
heads with with parts of the school
system that that wanted you to paint by
numbers and wanted you to move lockstep
with with with everyone else and wanted
you to just accept things without
questioning them and and yeah and
sometimes that that led to some some
issues number three number three could
you tell us about anyone experienced or
epiphany that you had that you may have
had while growing up that shaped your
current attitude towards learning and
teaching you know that there's a bunch I
think well you know the I think you know
one story is is that that we tell often
now because sean 'then who now works at
the khan academy he's the president here
he I first met him in 10th grade at a a
math competition and we met in the
finals of the math competition was this
district-wide math competition in the
last round it was misha afternoon is
another another boy and shot new did
beat me and so that was a good
experience a humbling experience but
above and beyond that while we were
competing we actually a little bit of a
conversation and actually turned out
that chaton was even though we were both
in the 10th grade he was a math class
ahead of me and and I asked was like how
did you how does that happen and he said
well I just test it out of the math
class you're taking right now and so for
me that was an epiphany that one that
that was even a possibility i went i
didn't went back to my high school and
when I told people about I told you know
I went back to the administration I said
hey can I test out of stuff too like oh
we're not aware of anything like that so
it but but what shot and who did is it
he he awakened the possibility that you
can do that it ended up being a lot
harder not harder in terms of the
subject matter mastery but a lot harder
in terms of convincing the system that
you should be allowed to test out of
something and once you do prove that you
know something that you should be
allowed to go into the next thing
but but that kind of gave me the energy
to do it and that that really did
accelerate my own learning and frankly
that allowed me to have a lot of those
experiences that I just mentioned
someone like dr. Santoni I would have
never ended up taking partial
differential equations at the University
of New Orleans while in high school had
I not had that that that that
conversation with Sean thenew do that
made that open my mind to the idea that
you really can kind of for lack of it
would fight the system and go at your
own pace I think other learnings you
know once once I started taking classes
at the University even in high school
you know University class attendance was
completely optional and I sometimes you
know I took advantage of that and I
realized that I did learn a lot better
from from a book then oftentimes in a
lecture it wasn't that lectures are
fundamentally bad I mean Here I am
someone making all these youtube videos
it's just that the book allowed me to
learn at my own pace if I was confused
by something I could read the same
passage 10 times if I found something
easy I didn't have to I could just skim
something and in lecture you kind of it
was hard to stay engaged i always found
that I was either lost or I was bored or
and very few times in a lecture that I
was exactly at the right place exactly
connecting with with kind of the pace of
the class and so you know at the
University of New Orleans where I spent
essentially my 10th and 11th my eleventh
and twelfth grades in in high school I I
a large degree showed up for the exams
but did a lot of self paced study and
that kind of carried with me when I went
to MIT is that I I I realized that you
know class time maybe it works for some
but it didn't work a lot for me I would
have loved class time that was
interactive that was their hands on I
loved lab time you know in all my
computer science classes I would skip
class and go to the computer lab and
work on my projects and I felt like I
was learning the material much better
than listening you know sitting in a
300-person lecture hall and listening to
a lecture about something it was much
better to fiddle with the thing and I
think the ideal would have been having
videos on demand so that if I was
curious about a topic I could get some
videos pause repeat watch them as much
as I need to but then have all this
extra time and preferably with the rest
of my peers and the professor around so
I could actually fiddle with stuff and
build stuff and those that's where I I
feel the best the best learning happens
and so that's what we're trying to do
with the Khan Academy we're trying to
make
class time about interaction and in
about fiddling and about helping each
other letting humans be humans and allow
a lot of the core skills to happen at
someone's own pace through on-demand
video and through and through exercise I
want to be clear you know I said that I
liked textbooks a lot and i still like
text books i'm reading many right now
but i think a combination of on demand
extra on demand videos and exercises
that give immediate feedback can be
better for the purposes of all of
self-paced learning i mean when i was 16
and I was kind of trying to you know
chug through some type of a you know an
ALICE book or a partial differential
equations book it's dense reading and
it's it took you know you had to kind of
be very persistent to kind of read
through that and I would have loved a 10
minute video on the exact topic that I
was ready for and I would have loved
practice problems where you don't just
have every other answer at the back of
the book you have immediate feedback you
know how to do the steps of that problem
you know what videos to watch if you
don't know how to do that problem and in
the videos they're not just it's not
just dry text it's actually someone
trying to communicate intuition to you
someone trying to in communicate now not
just the methodology but really the art
of the mathematics or the science
question number four question number
four what excites you most about
learning science well you know it really
is that science is all about really
trying to find the truth in the universe
you know we'll never probably know all
of the truth in the universe but I think
that's what separates humans from every
other species that we know is that we
are just naturally curious and we are
gent we're naturally in awe of the
mysteries of this universe and science
is is our best tool at trying to at
trying to demystify the mysterious and
having frankly what it does is it just
introduces even more and even more
profound mysteries the deeper and deeper
you go into science I just just this
journey in kind of working on the Khan
Academy videos I've gone so much deeper
in so many areas of science but it's
given me so much more appreciation for
how much deeper the open questions are
and so you know I think I think science
is science when you when someone is
really in science it really
is catering to those same you know it
caters to that part of the human
instinct that that gives you all that
get that that that that you start to
appreciate where you are in the universe
and what the universe might be about or
how are how intertwined and elegant the
universe we are we're in actually is so
it's you know I guess you know that yeah
I don't know what you know is I guess
it's just exciting question number five
question number five as a teacher who
has impacted so many lives do you have
any advice for our young readers who
find hard to concentrate on their
studies or perform well in exams yeah i
mean my main advice is as as much as you
can try to ponder what you are learning
don't just try to cram for an exam don't
try to memorize formulas if you feel
that the formulas you're looking at for
your current class are just beyond your
understanding then back up look at what
you learn last year the year before get
to a point where you can start to see
why those things are intuitive and
hopefully you watch Khan Academy videos
so that that's what we try to do show
you why these things are intuitive why
they aren't formulas to memorize and
once you start to ponder things it'll
you'll just talk to ponder things all
the time you know I mean my wife you
know jokes it often takes me half an
hour to throw out the trash because I
like take out the trash and while I'm
holding the trash can I sometimes I'm
just like staring out at the you know
the sky for like ten minutes because i'm
pondering something and and this may be
the most fun thing to be doing is
pondering something and and the more you
ponder something it gets your brain just
building connections and then as you
progress through more and more advanced
courses that they'll just start to see
more and more obvious you'll almost say
like why is this a new course this is
just a kind of a natural byproduct of
what i had already pondered and and you
know frankly it'll it'll it'll help you
not just in your academics i think it'll
help you be a more creative person and
that's frankly what's really really
really matters is the ability to see
things where maybe other people aren't
seeing things see way better ways of
doing things seeing innovations seeing
connections that other people aren't
seeing so i would say ponder as much as
you can learn as deeply as you can make
sure that your foundations are as strong
as you can
and you know and then after that if
there are if there is the mundane aspect
and there are mundane aspects of our
current school systems and our current
exams you know just view that as a game
as a game that lets you get to the good
stuff and that's how I viewed it I mean
there were definitely moments in my own
education rounds like this is silly
they're making me do this or that but I
said you know what I have to do this if
I if I want to get to a point where I
get to do more pondering and I get to
look at the really cool stuff so yeah I
would say view it it's a ponder as much
as you can so that you can really
distilled things to what's most
important and then the stuff that's
still not fun after that you know just
just remind yourself that it's a you
know it's it's a bit of a marathon and
and and you gotta it's it's going to get
you to where you're going so that your
life will be more fun at some point and
hopefully it's hopefully it's already a
little fun right now